thank you for joining us I'm John
langler we start with Three Fires at two
buildings in one morning this fire was
out on West Charleston it actually
flared back up after being initially put
out go to Las Vegas reporter Lauren
negretti live this afternoon near
Charleston and Decatur with the latest
Lauren good afternoon
good afternoon yes John Las Vegas fire
rescue crews are in the cleanup phase
now now for safety concerns it's still
too early to go inside because of that
you can see if my shoulder here's some
activity here as they are still keeping
an eye out so it does not flare up again
Las Vegas fire and rescue Battalion
Chief Joseph digitano says that no one
was injured after Crews battled the fire
for five hours he says they received
multiple calls around 5 30 and arrived
soon after while they did knock it down
it flared back up around 8 30 and they
were able to put it out a couple hours
later by 10 30.
there's a risk it could reignite that's
why we will continue firewatch for the
next several days to make sure that
nothing kicks back up and the
surrounding buildings are safe
battalion chief digitano says the Flames
are out but it's smolding material
that's trapped within that's still
smoking and that's what they are
concerned about now no word no word yet
on the cause of the fire and again it's
likely Crews will be out here for
several hours possibly days live near
Charleston and Decatur Lauren negretti 8
news now all right Lauren thank you very
much